oh no my vocal booth is leaking oxygen
got to save as many brain cells as i can
is there a simpler movie we can do this
week
moonfall that's just stupid enough to
work quick hand me the script
why is this written in crayon ah never
mind it'll have to do
getting dumber with
each breath
make
trailer
go now
[Music]
director roland emerick hate world his
movies make everything explode but with
nothing left on earth to boom now he
blow up
moon
moon fall
brain can't think oh well
the moon falling and it looks scary
america says why not nuke moon but first
three astronauts try to save it with a
little help from china the chinese are
offering their prototype moonlander
china good halle berry nice nasa lady
and also mom patrick wilson's sad nasa
man and also dad my favorite sam is
casey
no other favorite sam
he eat pills and say funny words
cat
enjoy a movie that won't let you forget
where is moon we have to go back to the
moon we have to see what's going on up
there i got a lot of my own problems
down here and the moon falling onto
earth isn't one of them the moon is
rising gravity's gonna go crazy and let
you know our heroes inside moon now does
he mean inside the moon how many brians
you think are inside the mall oh he dead
no we are just inside the moon and also
moon may be falling but hey moon not all
bad save the moon save earth the moon is
going to help us you're part of the moon
now moon good
science hard but not in moonfall all you
need is calculator see if the moon can
pull us the rest of the way casey can we
do it huh um come on buddy like how
spaceship can launch with no ground crew
look
missing engine how do you feel about
flying shuttle with only two engines
during tidal wave
or when they fly to the moon and get
close to star inside that's a white
dwarf without melting or eye protection
all to learn moon's ancient secret
aliens
or
we are aliens so the aliens that built
the moon
our ancestors and alexa evil so he
escaped in moon
alexa stop
stop not today meat bag
but movie not all about moon real moon
is family we made along the way because
back on earth divorced astronaut son is
in danger and other divorced astronaut
son is also in danger now survival
depends all on new lexus all right let
me put this baby in the water speak go
go lexus good and chinese exchange
student you don't leave people behind
okay china strong and that's all because
roland emmerich hates earth but roland
emrick hates step dads more
hey earth in ruins but dad can plow mom
again evens out
so buckle up for adventure that will
make you scared of large ball and sky at
night because inside that is robot cloud
that bangs your face
but don't be too scared we have enough
problems here on ground in fact nobody
in movie seems to get too worried
let's keep going
how did you get out dad got me out also
nobody in real life seems to care we
should get started
get started with what
it thinks it's a franchise funny
starring
worst astronaut since diaper lady
stat woman
samwell starley he's brian's son let's
call him i don't know sunny she can do
it may the moon be ever in your favor
okay so i'm at the planetarium benefit
right and these scientists are telling
me that the moon turns out not a moon
okay actually it's a mega structure
right it's filled with these tiny little
robot guys right and they're gonna crash
the moon into earth you know like kill
us all right now looming apocalypse so
anyway halle berry yeah bro catwoman but
on the costume you know just like
regular fine halle berry so she and
boats for
scale
[Music]
how about fly
wide rock down
what would elon do
call you a pedo for trying to help
this movie was filmed in front of a dead
audience
in the name of the moon i'll punish you
i'm starting to get hungry you won't
like me when i'm hungry
happy birthday james